hey everybody its Jessie and today we're
gonna do some more beginner friendly
stuff I guess so we're gonna work on
styling so mainly be dealing with CSS
with sass and possibly some of we'll be
looking at the material UI documentation
and trying to work with some of the
options that already come with the
components I'd rather work with the
options than try to override it but we
may have to just you know try to
override some stuff with our own CSS if
we have to do that that's okay too
I want to catch catch everyone up to
what I've been working on I guess the
end of yesterday and for this morning so
you can check out my Trello board and
see kind of what's moved around there's
a link in the description but mainly I
have set up a server so I have a droplet
on digitalocean I talked about going
through the set up in a stream but I
decided well for one I already did the
exact same set up for a last project and
I stream that so anybody who really
wants to see that can go back to the
last thing I stream the the other reason
is simply because a lot of it is just
following documentation and copy and
pasting commands and that's much easier
to do without making mistakes if I can
focus and not have to worry about
talking when I'm doing it and I was able
to get though everything set up and in
probably 40 minutes or less so it went
it went really quickly
you know I was able to focus so it's all
set up it has its running ubuntu 16.04
nginx is the reverse proxy node and it's
set up with a SSL and I pointed that
obviously I pointed a domain name to it
and set up the SSL and so that's already
the last step is simply to just bring in
the repository I'm just going to use git
for that so right before the stream
started I was just trying to set up the
SSH keys in my github account so that I
could just bring the bring the
repository right in so the flow of
updating will be I push from my local
machine to github and then I pull from
github into the server and then rebuild
everything and the updates will be live
at that point all right so let me say
hate everybody in the lab chat get a few
few you in there
Alex asks is there a playlist for these
videos yes there is a playlist and it's
called I don't know this code let me
check I think it's like maybe Jesse
builds a react app live something like
that I can if some if somebody knows put
in the live set otherwise I'm gonna look
it up on my other screen I add videos
every day to this playlist you think I'd
remember what the name of it is alright
flail is okay the playlist is called
Jesse builds a react project live that's
the playlist for just this project
project too if you want to see all the
videos including project one the
playlist is just live coding with Jesse
at some point I should probably split
them out into two different playlists
but for now that
how they're divided up so we are on day
29 no one day 30 so there are 29 videos
currently in the playlist this is number
30 we will be finishing this project up
pretty soon assuming there's not a lot
of changes whenever this gets reviewed
ok so quickly I'm gonna go over the the
changes that I've made and then we're
gonna start into style some things
there's a few things that are really
obvious that need style because they
just look a little bit weird and some
other areas where it already looks ok
we're just gonna make it look a little
bit better I am gonna start my comodoro
timer I'd like to get at probably like 2
or 3 sessions and depending on how many
questions we have and how many you know
how many people are in the in the live
chat so I'd like to get at least two
sessions and we'll see how it goes if
you're not familiar with the strain the
way things go
is this is just my everyday work that
I'm doing so whatever I need to work on
in my normal job as a front-end
developer I work on and I share it all
with you
I organize my work normally with in
Pomodoro sessions so we do 25-minute
code sessions and then in between we
take five-minute breaks and I answer
questions in the lab chat at the end of
the stream I answer all the questions
that that you all put in the live chat I
welcome any questions and also comments
and advice in the live chat as well
let's see I think that's my normal I
need to write down like my normal
explanation for the channels I don't
forget and then I can just rattle it off
at the beginning also I have a secondary
stream on Instagram so if you're
watching on
Instagram you can see my my monitors and
all the code at free code camp on their
YouTube channel so check out that
YouTube channel and this video is titled
styling react components in this project
to day 30 so check that out if you want
to see the code otherwise you'll just be
seeing my face which won't be that
helpful if you'd like to know more about
styling react components all right so
let's let's get started just you know
really quickly showing what I've done
the mainly my work has been other than
setting up the server my work has been
on this service request form if you
remember we had a branch that was the
file type check branch and we were doing
some work with form validation on that
branch that's now been merged into
master I got it to the point where I
thought you know it was it was ready not
perfect but functional and so that's
merged now in the master so if you're
checking out the repository the links in
the description the master branch now
has has everything in it there are no
side branches that are being worked on
currently so here's what I've done and
you can see so this is what it it did
look like with the check boxes so we had
basically you know these icons when you
clicked it it just came up with an alert
basically just to say like hey it works
when you click on this and we had the
check boxes now I've redone the check
boxes so that a few few improvements so
this was a really big step done by
Sebastian and I just kind of finished
that up over here and that now depending
on what data you pass into the component
you could get an icon that icon could be
whatever you want it doesn't have to be
the information icon and then when you
click on it a modal opens you can pass
in a title and then you can pass in HTML
style you know however you want and
currently this is this is what we have
so just you know regular unordered list
I'll show you all the code for this also
you know the check boxes work now we
have a separate component that so we're
passing you know the click event up to
the parent component which is this whole
page I'll show you how that works so
what I ended up doing was I split if you
remember our problem was trying to get
the check box and the icon together and
being able to click on it get different
information so that was we were just
trying to figure out the best way to do
that I think at some point last week so
this is what I came up with so now
instead of doing all this in the service
request form which is already getting
quite large
I just separated out into another
component so this is called the icon
check box component so here's what we're
doing the only state that we're even
tracking here is just for the modal
we're leaving the state for the check
box itself whether or not it's checked
here in the parent component of service
request j/s because we want all that
data all that form data to stay in state
here so we can send it you know we can
read that we can send it off to our
server j/s file and then handle all that
form data from there so that's why I
left it here otherwise normally I would
handle you know component state I mean
assuming I wasn't you know using some
other state management technique but for
something basic I will probably just
handle state right here in the component
like I'm doing here but it makes more
sense in this case to do it the parent
component and I'm not using Redux or
anything like that for this so I usually
get people
are you using redox or why don't you use
redox so this is a simple enough react
project that I didn't really think it
needed Redux I'm also not that great
with Redux yet to even be confident and
implementing it but I am trying to learn
currently on on another project okay so
pretty basic we just have a handle
dialogue open handle dialogue close okay
this is nothing different than what
we're already doing in this component
with our dialogue for when when you
submit the form so we actually didn't
have a handle dialog open because that
was handled in the form submission
function so we just added that in now
down here we have our check box and this
is our material UI check box but then
depending on the value for icon
I think it's passed and let me show you
on on the right side where we pass this
in you can see this is a very large
component it's
yeah down here down here there we go
I'm think I'm gonna make this a bit
bigger a bit wider here it'll be a lot
easier to read okay so here we go here's
our icon check box components and you
see it's capable of taking in a lot of a
lot of properties so we're passing in
things for the check box and these are
all just normal things that you pass in
for the material you I component the
same thing that we're doing right down
here this these checkboxes are the old
way that we were doing it okay so it's
the same thing the only thing that's
even you know slightly different here is
and on check we pass the event up right
to our handle check here and then it
calls handle input change and passes
that event on right you see otherwise
right we all we had to do was on check
call handle input change but now that
we've put this into another component we
have to pass that event I actually had I
had a big I spent a lot of time trying
to troubleshoot this because I couldn't
get it to work and it turns out I was
doing everything right except I was
passing in label here instead of name so
it was trying to update the information
in state for a component that didn't
even exist I'm sorry for a checkbox that
didn't exist right because the labels
uppercase but the name is lowercase so
anyway that was pretty frustrating
definitely would have saved like a half
an hour of kind of back-and-forth
troubleshooting if I would have just
passed in the right prop so that happens
sometimes
so anyway the checkbox like I said other
than this it operates exactly the same
and here's the kind of the new portion
so if this is true so we have C we have
icon here so basically within our data I
guess I should share the data because
that might make a little bit more sense
so here's our data for our checkboxes so
we can pass in a lot more now than we
were before see before we basically a
name info you can either put an icon
false like we're doing here or it'll
check and if the icon data doesn't even
exist it'll automatically pass in false
so I filled this in before I put this
check in for that so but it really
doesn't matter I'll probably end up
taking out the icon false just to keep
things a little bit a little bit shorter
in here but in this case for that first
check box you can see we're passing in
the name the info text I'm actually not
using this now so I'll get rid of this
this was Sebastian and put this in just
kind of more as an example like hey
here's where you put in your data so we
do have icon true now here's where we
have that everything for the modal so we
get passing the title for the modal and
then for dialogue text we put in our
HTML and I have this inside a template
literal that way I don't have to worry
about using single or double quotes
inside of here it's just it's kind of
easy I think I'm only using a single
quote yeah so you know right here but
potentially I could be using them you
know in more places so if you can use
template literal definitely recommend
that if you're gonna put a lot of
content in there so you can see this is
just you know regular HTML normally I
wouldn't want to have like huge blocks
of HTML in here but we're not really
gonna do this often in fact this my
be the only checkbox that even gets
extra info so we'll see maybe once the
people in my department see that this is
possible they might want extra info for
some other things as well but I don't
think we'll have anything nearly this
big otherwise our data file is gonna get
huge okay so there's our data and you
can see we're passing that in so here's
the icon so we have this as an image and
then our source is just gonna be our
source from the source with the SVG is
so let me go up to the top here's who
we're bringing in that so we're
importing info logo from image info dot
SVG all right so we're pulling that in
here and then we're passing it in props
so we could pass in anything we wanted
in terms of a logo really we could bring
in a source for an image if we wanted to
I guess I don't know how great that
would look probably not that good since
we're intending it to be a logo but and
then we are also putting in an alt tag
currently I think I just have hard-coded
let me double check on that I do it just
says info button really I think we just
need an alt or else it'll react I'll
complain either reactor I don't know if
it's specific to create rec react app
but I'm pretty sure that's what was
happening before so I mean it's a good
idea to have alt text anyway if I get a
new situation where I have lots of
different logos in here then I'd
probably want to put it in our data file
and pass incorrect
alt text but right now the only thing
we're gonna have our info button so that
works all right and that's it to get the
the logo and we have you know some
positioning here but other than that we
have our dialogue so this
is our material UI dialog component and
we're just passing in the title and then
here this is how we can use the HTML so
inside of this dialog component I have a
span and we're dangerously setting the
inner HTML you can't do that on the
actual dialog component itself because
this component ends up outputting you
know several other divs inside of it so
I've tried tried it it does not work so
you need to put a span inside and then
anything inside here is going to be put
in the right place within that modal
within that dialog so we just have a
span here we're setting the dangerously
setting the interests UML if we didn't
do it like this then the user would
actually see all the HTML tags when you
do this though it's a good idea to only
do this if you have complete control of
the data you're not gonna have like
users submitted data in there but as
long as you have control your data this
is fine even though it it seems
dangerous it's it's completely fine if
if you know for sure what's going to be
coming through here okay and that's
that's pretty much it that's all I've
done yeah at least that's all I can
remember that I've done since yesterday
so I just need to apply that same thing
to this side and we need to do a bit of
styling so that we don't have this huge
gap between checkboxes so we can come
back to that styling but I'd like to
work on the home page first all right
because this is what this will people
are gonna see right off the bat if
there's any page I want to spend the
most time on in terms of style it's
definitely going to be the home page
it's entirely possible that the majority
of people won't see you know a lot of
these other these other views but we
know you know this looks really plain
I'd like to put in I have some ideas for
what I'd like to put in so let's just
try them out and see if you all have any
ideas for what
make this look a bit less plain I mean
I'm I'm really I like the clean look but
this is almost sterile you know it's
it's like beyond clean at this point so
like to add a little bit in maybe a
little bit of color possibly some icons
we'll see I don't want to go crazy with
the icons then it's it's just kind of
hard you know you want to try to find
different types of icons when you end up
throwing things in there that don't even
they don't then make sense so I'd rather
not put an IKE I'd rather not just throw
in icons just for something to look at
if they don't mean really mean anything
so first we're just going to try adding
in some color and see how that looks
like I said I wonder trying to get about
the screen this is more like the screen
size that's common here at the
University so I'd like to try try to
keep that in mind as we're styling this
so my monitor is way bigger than the
normal screen size of people that work
here yeah I think that's about it off
the double check the analytics and see
what kind of screens we get mostly I do
want to double check the live chat let's
see
okay I just want to remember to check in
case you know occasionally I'm doing
something really wrong and you all let
me know a lot in the live chat so didn't
want to go too long without at least
taking a peek at it here's what I'm
thinking I'd like to maybe put a border
on the left of each of these titles and
I'd like to mess around with some of the
different colors that are available in
the university's color palette and just
see how it looks
I'm not you know I kind of have an idea
in my head of how it will look but you
never know until you really you know get
it on there and see not really sure how
would it look to with the colors you
know should we do more than one how many
more should we alternate so let's just
do it and see what it looks like
so this
maybe we'll put
I think I'd like to add a class to this
I guess to this span yeah we're gonna
have to do it to this span
let's see let's check out our components
see how this is we may not be able to
easily add a class but if we just select
the first fan I think we should be fine
so let's see we're using the component
for a components generic car that's it
yes we're using a generic card and card
header so there's the title okay so it's
in the card title okay I don't want to
put it in this style here because like
we saw here
this applies I should make this a bit
bigger it's easy for you to see see if
you can see here that styling is applied
- I believe that's applied to this div
and if I try to put a border on this dev
it's gonna be bigger than we want so I
want to target that span yeah
all right let's do that let's just try
to do it in in CSS then unless I mean
it's possible that there's a way to
target that interior span with material
UI but I'm guessing not just from what
I've seen from the other components that
we worked with so let's go leave our
home dot s CSS file and let's actually
bring out our home component and
the card container all right let's see
if this will allow us to to get that
span there we go so we have
okay
all right that should work
I guess I could have just used flex then
like I did up here but if I'm using what
I want to avoid is having these styles
spill over into other places where I
don't want them so that's why we added
this here
okay and I will say when you're doing
styles for react there are so many ways
right now to do it this is just one of
those those ways there are a lot of
different ways to do your CSS right in
the component and then in this
particular way we're using sass which
certainly don't have to use so I don't I
don't want to make it seem like this is
the way to do it this is just one way to
do it and in fact we did it very
differently on the last project so if
you want to see an alternative you could
check that out but we just you know we
happen to be doing it this way on this
project I I have not made up my mind as
to what way I like the best so I'm still
kind of trying different things out and
hopefully at some point I'll settle on
on some consistent way of doing it but
I'm not there yet okay and let's go with
for now we can just target the span
because the other span right now is a
height of zero pixels so I mean we'll
see in a second but it shouldn't it
shouldn't do anything if we put a border
on that so let's go the border left and
solid let's try let's try two pixels we
may have to go three but I want to see
what - looks like first and then I don't
what color I want to try first
I'm gonna grab let's grab this color
and I need to set up my sash right now
is not set up it's not taking advantage
of a lot of things that SAS can do and
it should it should be just haven't
really taken the time to get everything
set up properly yet you know normally we
would want to be importing all our
variables into our SAS files so that we
could use those variables so you know
for sure our color variables your color
palette we want to have them be all
variables but you know probably some
other things as well all right yeah
that's terrible I don't like that okay
here's what we need to do all right so
this definitely needs to be more than
two pixels I'm gonna go three pixels
right now and yeah I don't like that
all right let's try this out so let's
decrease our line height
we're gonna make our lion height the
same as our font size now that brings
this kind of shrinks it up a little bit
too much but okay so that's in line so
we're gonna have to use important we're
gonna have to use important to override
those inline Styles you do want to be
careful when you use important because
obviously it's it's going to be more
difficult if you you're basically
undoing the cascading nature of
cascading style sheets when you use
something like this so you don't use it
all the time but in this case this is
just so much easier than trying to dig
into the components and figure out I
just really don't want to edit the
material UI components directly I'd
rather try to do things on top of that
and we want to add in some padding left
of let's try four pixels we'll see how
that looks okay all right yeah I like
that
[Music]
and we won margin what a margin on the
bottom and the top of let's go with
eight pixels and then went zero on the
sides okay yeah that gives us back to
the same spacing that we had originally
or at least pretty close to it now I
think I'd like to have our text lined up
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go
we'll go we'll keep our eight pixels on
top we'll go zero on the right and then
we'll do eight pixels on the bottom and
then on the left I'm gonna go with
negative let's see we're doing padding
there four pixels let's go negative
let's it's gonna probably gonna be too
much we'll try it first just to start
okay that's not bad it's pretty close
yeah I think seven seven is better right
that makes sense because we've added a 4
pixel padding left and then we have a 3
pixel border so 7 pixels puts us back
where you were that way we have our text
lined up I think that looks a bit nicer
let me know what you think though okay
so we have this did we put our padding
in already I think I'm gonna copy both
of these
and we're gonna have to use did I add
these I don't think we'll have to use
important because I think I added these
both in so let's see if it works I'm
gonna save that yep all right so it did
work so now we have a little bit of
color I'm not I don't really know if I
like it or not let's see my timer did go
off a few minutes ago and I just wanted
to finish that up so you have something
to look at I'm gonna take a short break
now and go to the live chat and see what
you all think and also if there's any
questions I'll try to answer as many as
I can in this is five minutes
okay so John John Hanson says I believe
most react components work best passing
down function rather than passing up is
this true JavaScript and suffer from
bubbling can this happen in react to yet
I guess I think this question probably
came when we were going over the icon
checkbox and passing us up so basically
yeah normally you do want to pass things
down to from parent to child and react
but sometimes you have to in certain
situations like this one you you do have
a child component and it needs to let
the parent component know what's
happening normally I've only had this
situation happen where I have inputs
that are in child components and I need
to let the parent component know if
something is changed with that input so
there are probably other situations
where you'd want to but I haven't dealt
with them yeah yeah probably inputs are
the the main thing so in that case I I
think I haven't found any negative let's
see side effects from from doing it like
that not to say that they don't exist I
just haven't encountered them yet
[Music]
pravin ask what is react learning curve
I mean how much time will it take for
basic JavaScript developer angularjs new
developer to learn react jeaious and
react native it's hard to say how much
time really because that depends it
depends on how much time you have to
dedicate to it every day that I get to
learning it and how quick of a learner
you are and how much you already know so
it's really it would be hard
to say I can only speak for myself I
started working with reacts I want to
say it's been less than a year since
I've been working with react so it took
me it took me probably a few months
before I before I actually launched a
react site for a client before that you
know I I just done some some things just
to learn really I didn't have all day to
dedicate to it I was working on other
projects that weren't you know where I
wasn't using react so I would I would
say if you could dedicate let's say you
could dedicate all your time to it you
can get pretty good with reacting in a
month or less you know I'm talking like
full-time learning you know building
things otherwise if you're working a
full-time job you know you have those
projects you know I'd say a couple of
months but like I said it's really hard
to say it's it's kind of an individual
thing there's a lot of factors that
would go into that some guy responds
respond to that question learn
JavaScript first at least the basics up
to objects and go through x6 then start
learning concepts of react mainly
components yes I mean you're definitely
going to need to know some JavaScript to
be able to know react you don't need to
be an expert in JavaScript oh certainly
you'll your JavaScript skills will get
better as you learn react as well so if
you if you did want to jump into react
it's it's probably fine you know if you
have limited knowledge of JavaScript
it'll just be harder to get through
react but you know eventually your
skills will they'll have to get better
if you want to be good at react
perviness
is es6 necessary to learn react
I don't necessary to know all of the
Essex but es6 will help make things
easier I mean even even just the
syntactic sugar part of es6 will make
things easier but yeah I would say it's
not like there's that much to es6 or
es2015 whatever I I read a comment to a
blog post earlier where somebody was so
mad that someone said es8 instead of es
2017 so I don't wanna make anybody mad
officially I think it's we're going with
the es 2015 16 17 but in any case yeah
you can get started with react without
great knowledge of es6 but it's your
life will be easier if you learn it and
then Praveen says can you suggest some
links or references to learn and let's
see some suggestions were Codecademy
yeah I've done their react stuff that's
good Udacity has a react course it's
paid though so it depends on your budget
for you know for learning materials for
react if you want to stick with the free
stuff code Academy is good and then I
mean there's so many YouTube videos that
could be helpful lets trying to think
learn code Academy is a YouTube channel
that has a lot of good videos and has
some serious on react actually earlier
today I was just watching a video on
Redux on that channel I think will Stern
is the guy that does all the videos on
that channel so you can check that out
the react tutorials on that channel are
a little bit older so there might be
some updates to the way things are done
but the overall concepts are still the
same and react so those would be just
off the top of my head that's
probably one of the best channels that
I've personally watched for react stuff
on YouTube and then certainly you know
these streams you'll pick up a lot about
react on these streams but these you
know it's not really a tutorial so
there'll be a lot of gaps like this is
not a systematic way of learning react
it's just you get to see what I happen
to be doing at 2:00 p.m. every day
okay
all right my time I did go off so I'm
not through the chat so I'm gonna have
to come back to that so if I didn't get
to your question yet don't worry I'll
get to it in our next break or towards
the end of the stream and if you can't
stick around for the live stream to get
the answer you can always check out the
recording that's available on a free
code camp YouTube channel later on and
then you'll be able to hear the answer
answer there let's see all right let's
reset this do another 25-minute session
okay I'm gonna scroll down to the bottom
and see if anyone had any comments on
the styles okay all right so John Hanson
is not a fan of the border on the left
okay I don't think I'm thinking anybody
else so if anybody else has an opinion
on this let me know like I said after I
saw it I'm not I don't hate it but I'm
not I'm not sure that this is exactly
what what we need here I mean I think
maybe it's better than nothing
it's part of the thing that that is
bothering me about this too is that we
have this this one card this the title
is going it down on the two lines
there's not really anything we can do
about that
yes
I mean we can try you know know what I
would like to try I think I want this
text this how can Markham help you text
to be permanently closer to the top and
then have these centered so basically
right now
this is vertically centered but the
entire div is vertically centered
including this so what what happens is
all of this appears to not be centered
it appears to be towards the bottom more
so what I'd like to do is take this out
of that div so this isn't taken into
consideration for the centering and then
have these come up a little bit I think
depending on the screen size it's not
going to be that big of a difference but
I do think it'll help it will help out a
blank space on the bottom is not as big
of a deal as blank space on the top when
there's blank space on the top it really
I think feels like there's something
missing but the bottom of the page is
you know that's just the bottom right
it's not as big of a deal at least I
don't know at least in my mind that's
that's how it seems to me so let's uh
let's do that I want to do that for sure
and then we can think more about what
we're gonna do in terms of color in here
John says how about a four pixel top
border on each card with the same color
okay so we could do yeah I guess I guess
we could try that so we'll try that too
let me get rid of this because I know
for sure that I want to kind of mess
with this vertical centering a bit and
then we'll try that border on the top so
John just just to be clear are we
talking like
border that stretches completely across
the card I think that would look the
best I'm assuming that's what we're
talking about
okay John also says don't take the
heading out of the div just add padding
to the bottom to Center it better all
right let's see
that's it we'll make this bigger just to
kind of exaggerate the issue as well so
we can see what's going on here I'm just
I'm wondering would it look see it
because in this case it's really obvious
you know if we had this so that it was
always up at the top you know there's a
huge difference here
I'm kind of wondering if maybe it was a
mistake to vertically Center this maybe
it would be better if this was just you
know at the top I don't know let me know
what you all think about that is
originally we did not have this
vertically centered and I said it's not
as big of a deal on a smaller screen
when you end up getting into larger
sizes it's just there's just so much
space up here I don't I don't know that
that that looks right all right so let's
we'll try a few things and see see what
looks best
okay so here's our
actually let's just let's take this out
and see what it would look like that'll
be the easiest thing to check so here's
what it looks like without being
vertically centered
okay I
yeah I like I think this looks good and
it looks like at least a few you agree
much better okay great yeah I agree I
think that does look a lot better I
can't I can't remember what we were
thinking originally with that vertical
Center I mean it was cool when we did it
at least it was a nice demonstration of
how to do a vertical Center with with
flexbox but yeah definitely definitely
looks better okay we'll leave it like
that now let's try out that that top
border actually though I didn't think
about this either but we could
potentially do a a border on the side
that takes up the entire height of the
card so what do you think well I'll try
them both we'll try a top border and
then we'll also try the side border
maybe I'll do it on on two different
cards here so we can see it side by side
okay
maybe I can just do it right here in dev
tools
I'll get fry just copy copy this edit it
a bit
okay so here's our left our left border
and let's do the same thing over here
but we're gonna do top and we'll make
this 4 as well okay
all right so what do y'all think on the
side on the top or I definitely don't
think bottom would look good but we
could we could try on the right as well
okay Zachary asked if I'm feeling better
I don't know I feel kind of the same so
if you watch the last last show I was
not feeling well so still about the same
my throat hurts a little bit less than
it did though so that's good but I
started I'm a little bit congested so I
don't know if I'm getting better it's
just transitioning into something
different but I'm still so just tired
that's that's the worst thing is like I
just I feel like I have no energy but
I'm starting to get some of my focus
back I feel like today the last like two
weeks I just feel like my work has not
been great I don't know if it's been
evident in the streams or not but it
just feels I don't know I feel like I'm
not doing good work like I'm having
trouble focusing on my work and so
anyway today I finally like really made
an effort to really try to focus and
like work through the the tiredness and
I think I did I think I did a decent job
on that logo checkbox component and I
worked through some some bugs and stuff
and so hopefully this is the start of me
getting back into it but just just tired
and just lack of motivation that's
what's bothering me the most anyway
thanks for asking Zachary sorry for the
big explanation I know you all may not
have wanted that much information but it
I wanted to give everybody a chance to
weigh in on these anyway so it was a
good point a good time to talk a bit all
right so I'm gonna check out what
everyone said okay so it looks like left
left just listening to service
okay so oh man so we did have a bunch of
votes four on the left on the side now
we have some for the top someone did say
so Laura said make it at the left border
when you mouse-over all right so we
don't we don't really have consensus
here here's what I'm gonna do I think it
might be better if we saw what it would
look like if all of them had had the
border so we'll try I'll do all of them
with the the top border I'll take a
screenshot and we'll do all with the
border on the side and then we can look
at them side by side that might give us
a better idea
since we're we're kind of torn right now
so let's take let's take this for now
and okay so for now
let's do this
and instead let me check
okay so try this one first oops and I'll
get rid of this whoops I said it order
laughs we were to that one okay so let
me screenshot this loose
let me make sure that worked I don't
think it did
and I can't remember I just do one of
these then I can't remember how to do a
just a regular screenshot on on a Mac
this one is gonna copy it to my
clipboard how do I do it alright
somebody help me out on a Mac what's the
shortcut to do a screenshot that will
automatically save to my desktop
I always just use the one where it's
copy to clipboard that's the command
ctrl shift 4 is it
okay there we go now I now I heard the
little click command
all right now weird this safe - I think
this is it all right great
okay so now we'll change it
oops
okay
so
not exactly equivalent here okay what do
you think top or side now that we can
see them side by side also I'm not
opposed to some sort of hover effect so
I mean obviously we already have I don't
want to overdo it right we already have
a hover effect going on here so if we
were add anything else having to do with
this border it wouldn't it would need to
be subtle so I'll give everybody maybe
like 20 seconds more to let me know what
your thing
okay it looks like all right we we have
we have a lot of votes for left now
we definitely have one for top we have
an undecided
Patrick says we could change maybe
change the border color on hover yeah I
think that's definitely I definitely
want to see how it looks
I'm not sure try to picture in my head
I'm not sure if it'll work or not but I
think it's worth a try I think we're
gonna go with the left then it seems
like it's now that we've seen them side
by side it seems like it's pretty almost
unanimous oh my goodness I keep my my
slack channel for work is just going
crazy I keep hearing the the noise that
I've got a new message so I don't think
I keep glancing at it it's nothing that
I need to respond to you right now but
it's a little bit distracting all right
so let's go with this I do want to check
let's let's see about changing the color
also yeah we'll see about changing the
color and then we'll see you know is
this enough to make the page not quite
so plain you know not not so stark so
I'm still thinking about it
now that I see this I wonder if I should
get rid of the border-radius
on this side if that would look nicer I
know cards normally you're supposed to
have a two picture border-radius of
material design but with this border on
the side I don't know that I like it
being slightly rounded I mean that maybe
I'm worrying too much about that but
let's try that I do let's try getting
rid of the border radius on this side
with the border and then also doing a
change of color on hover
where it is top left
oops I'm going bottom
shoot how does he area
let's try I don't know if I have any of
the other colors we'll put this color in
for now just to see may want to go with
a different color there are a few
there's a dark blue and a light blue
that's in the the cool color palette for
the University which is generally what I
like to use for websites we have a warm
color palette that has some Reds in
there but I just I'm not crazy about how
it looks on a screen it's definitely
better for print materials let's show
this up
they don't get the auto reload hmm
I bet you that I have to do all right so
that works but I think for this I'll
probably have to do important so I'm not
even gonna check I'm just gonna do it
since we're just testing this out anyway
there we go
okay so hmm
you see the difference well I guess
that's on the top
hmm
okay so I guess two things one what do
you think about the color the change of
color and the second thing is what about
the border-radius
I mean is it even noticeable let's
I'm gonna get rid of that here and just
try it try to just do it on one and dev
tools
okay so now we can see I guess better
the difference so the top one has no
border radius for this side and then
this bottom one it has the normal two
pixel border radius I don't know I want
to know what you all think for me now
that I look at this it I don't think it
looks right it almost seems like this is
now not part of the card especially
around the edges like it just looks I
don't know it looks like it's just added
or like this definitely looks like it's
within the card here I don't know what
do y'all think
use the green did I use the green yeah
okay this it's it's probably just some
type of weird thing going on with my
eyes when the transition from the yellow
but that this looks blue to me when I
hover over it like this obviously looks
green but for some reason this board is
looking blue
all right so Johnson keep the border
radius
okay
alright Johnson the border color needs
to be a bit softer so I'm assuming you
mean like this yellow and so it seems
like we're going to so we're not going
to change the border radius and okay
and then we're probably gonna soften
this color or we could try different
colors I need to bring in the some of
the other the colors from the like the
blues and stuff and see if one of those
looks look good here as well I mean
normally this yellow ends up being like
the accent color anyway but I have used
some of the Blues before and especially
the the dark blue is nice I've used it
before and it's it's pretty nice
occasionally to use it's just not it's
not really recognizable as a color for
our University even though it is in the
color palette it's not it's not often
used but that was the end of my Poe
Maduro session so I'm gonna do another
five minutes to go back to the live chat
I'm going to scroll back up to where I
left off on our last break and go
through and and just answer some more
questions
so I'm scrolling all the way up to the
way the timestamp is 227 p.m. for me
it'll be different depending on your
timezone but that's Eastern Time 227
p.m.
okay
say god says by the way great work all
at pre-code camp thank you I appreciate
that and at least thanks for the little
bit that I'm doing things you're saying
that I know there's a lot of people a
lot of people don't work for free code
camp and a lot of people that you never
even hear about or don't you know don't
know about so definitely the just a ton
of volunteers making it making it have
everything the free code camp does the
YouTube channel the website the the
blogs the forum a lot of a lot of
volunteers behind all that
Oh pravin mentioned YouTube's new
dark-themed yeah I think the dark thing
for YouTube is really cool so I just I
just wanted to read that comment out so
if you haven't checked it out yet check
out the settings on on YouTube and try
the dark theme I think I like dark
themes for pretty much everything so I
was really excited when that came out
Juno says greetings from Costa Rica
welcome thanks for watching
Kat bill says styled components is is
quite nice library for creating
beautiful react components yeah yeah
definitely I think before you know I was
saying there's lots of different ways to
style react components that's definitely
one of the ways that that I've seen and
like I said I'd like to try more of them
out before I decide which one I want to
stick with mainly no beer says hi from
Bangladesh hey welcome thanks for
watching
Daniel says hi Jessie and guys from
Romania hey Daniel welcome no beer says
hi I'm new here
well welcome really glad that that
you're watching thank you and thanks for
for letting us know that you're here in
the live chat feel free to contribute or
ask any questions and try to try to give
you the best answers that I can and
there's a lot of the really
knowledgeable people here in the live
chat that can definitely give you some
great answers some guy asks are you
using bootstrap for mobile responsive no
I'm not using bootstrap I'm using the
tier of UI so I guess it's not exactly
the same as bootstrap since material I
comes with these pre-made react
components but it's the same concept in
the sense that there's a lot of styling
things that are that are already there
although now that I think about it in
terms of the responsiveness right some
of that we did borrow from a framework
called materialized CSS so which which
is very much like bootstrap so
essentially materialized is a material
design CSS framework that does all the
same things that bootstrap does but just
in the material design style so we did
borrow the mainly we borrow their column
class system to help you know with the
different screen sizes and kind of
stacking the columns and things and we
borrowed a few other things so so that's
that's how we're handling responsiveness
right now
all right timer just is up so last one
sir key gaming says I started free code
camp about five days ago and got to the
tribute page but it seems like hardly
any of the things I learned stuck would
you say that's normal or is there other
things I can do let's see Lara's
response to that it's normal just jump
back and look over things go search on
the web if you can't do things you want
to do asking the Gator channel if you're
really stuck yeah yeah definitely
sometimes things don't stick the only
way to really have things stick in your
head is repetition I found and I don't
mean in the sense of like getting it
flashcards and memorizing like commands
but just actually building things like
day in day out you know building things
with whatever you're trying to learn a
little bit every day is much better than
you know like twelve hours one day and
then nothing for two weeks right so if
you were to spread that out and just do
you know an hour or so every day you're
definitely going to get more out of that
it's going to stay fresh in your brain
and you know you you will remember that
so alright let's go let me check the
time okay what do you I'm trying to
decide whether we should do another
session or whether I should go to
questions now we're already at about an
hour and 20 minutes for the video if I
do another session it's definitely going
to be a two-hour video for sure I will
my throat is I can feel my my throat
just getting more sore as this goes on
when I keep talking man
let me see how much we have left in the
in the chat I'm only about halfway
through right now all right front so I
think I'm not gonna do another Promotora
session we only got two in but I think
at this point I'd rather I'd rather end
now and save my voice so that I can do
sessions for the next two days then try
to overdo it and lose my voice so at
least we got we got through the homepage
which as I said I think the homepage is
the most important to get styling right
this is the first thing people are going
to see and they're gonna make a judgment
on the site based on this so I don't
know I think this looks a lot better
from what we had just an hour ago
definitely got a lot of good advice from
you all so thanks and I'm definitely
gonna mess around with the colors a bit
and see see what color combinations
might work and then I you know tomorrow
we can we can check it out and review
you know which colors look the best but
for now so I'm gonna stop the code
portion and I'm gonna go to the question
and answer session so if you just here
for the code and you can't stick around
for the question answer session thank
you so much for watching and I'll be
back tomorrow so you know come back if
you can and otherwise if you can stick
around you have a few more minutes and
if you have a question please put that
in the live chat now I'll do my best to
answer it and any any type of question
don't worry if you think it's like a new
question or anything you know don't
worry about that you know I definitely
want to be as welcoming as possible to
people who are new and help you out any
way that I can if you don't really have
a question I appreciate you sticking
around and helping to answer questions
and a live chat you know if you can if
you have the time
so I said I'm about halfway through the
live chat now so I'm just gonna keep on
going down and try to answer things once
we get through all the questions and
I'll I'll be finished with the stream so
I'm thinking we'll see probably
streaming for at least another ten
minutes kind of based on how many how
much is left in the live chat but we'll
see sometimes I talk for a while so
we'll see definitely want to keep this
below two hours just cuz just because
I'm pretty tight
alright shine as what is better react or
view in the future well I mean I don't
really know about what's gonna happen
with them in the future and I'll say I
don't think I can answer that question
properly because I haven't used view yet
I certainly have seen you know people
who are well respected in the industry I
guess and they really like view and they
use it so I've you know I'm assuming
that there's some really good things
about view but I don't really know
enough to do a comparison about it but
in terms of react the only thing going
against react right now that I see is
like a serious thing that could threaten
how widely it's used is the whole
license thing you know there's a there's
a lot of people that are freaking out
over the license and I don't really know
how many people but based on what's
going on on Twitter it seems like a lot
of people are now I know Twitter is just
a small a small portion of all the
people in the world and all the
developers so maybe it's not as big of a
deal as it seems like on Twitter but
other than that it seems like react is
pretty strong this there's more and more
people developing with react if you look
at like the trends just in terms of like
Google search trends and things or the
number of jobs that are you asking for
reactive elders it's it's going strong
it's still on the on the trend upward so
I'm not really worried about react going
anywhere anytime soon also I think
there's a lot of opportunity in terms of
react native and being able to use react
for VR stuff I think that's really cool
and potentially like depending on how
quickly VR grows react could grow right
along with that I don't know you know
there's just a lot of a lot of what-ifs
there but
I think you're probably either either
way with react or review you got at
least a few more years before you'd have
to think about learning something
different
okay you know what I did notice this
before but Oh Morris had mentioned when
we were doing these boxes to expand the
boxes and it would be better huh that's
interesting okay so yeah potentially I
mean obviously on a smaller screen right
there the boxes are fine but on a large
screen there is quite a lot of space you
know maybe maybe I should think about
expanding them maybe adding some sort of
at a certain breakpoint you know just
having a minimum height and width well
maybe I'll have to mess with that a
little bit and see see what works if
that looks a little bit better than then
all this blank space I'd say thanks for
that suggestion Omar
okay our reo says thing is mouse-over
already add shadow effect so we're
talking about the shadow yeah I I agree
there we do already have that shadow
effect which is why I'm still not a
hundred percent sure even about the
color change thing I'm not I'm not
totally against it but I just wonder is
it necessary since we already have the
the shadow you know getting the shadow
increasing on hover I'm just I'm not
really a big fan of doing too much on
hover so we'll have to yeah I'll have to
think about it
I mean one bonus is if I decide not to
do the color change thing and then we
don't that's one less color I have to
worry about picking so it simplifies it
a bit if we do that I mean in terms of
code it's it's trivial to add that
effect you know it's just one line but
in terms of thinking about the best
color combination for that that's what
that's what takes a lot that's what all
second guess
okay now I see a lot of people help me
out with the shortcut for screenshotting
on a Mac so thanks everyone who who
answered that sorry I just totally
forgot that that's your cut that happens
sometimes I guess
okay scrolling through actually a lot of
the stuff in the live chat was based on
just kind of what we were doing here so
that's why I'm skipping over a lot of it
because we've already talked about it
somebody put a hex code in I want to see
what the hex code is so I'm just I'm
gonna put it in here but it's just
popping in the background to see what it
is okay I like that green color I can't
use it here because I'm really kind of
limited to the official color palette
for the University but that's a really
nice color anyway thanks you that Pavel
thanks for they sue putting that X color
in I kind of really it's like a nice
like chill color green anyway just
wanted to check it out we're not we're
not gonna use that but I do like it
get get seen says talk about sanitizing
user inputs once you style them with
styled components
I guess did we do I don't think we've
done anything on a stream about
sanitizing input so maybe there's not
going to be a lot of streams left before
this projects finished but maybe I'll
think about talking about that more on
an on an upcoming stream one thing we
don't because we don't have a database
for this I'm not I'm not super worried
about sanitizing inputs in terms of like
I don't have to worry about something
like like sequel injection there's
something like that so I mean where I
don't want to just allow anything so but
it's not there's no danger of something
weird happening with the database but
anyway that's if I can in the few
streams that we'll have left for this
project I'll definitely talk about
sanitizing user inputs Gouffran says
sometimes using material design looks
too generic for me no offense yeah
that's the I think that's that's kind of
what's happening with material design I
don't completely disagree so I still
like material design and I'm still going
to continue to use it there's I think
there's a lot of good reasons to use
material design one of the main ones
being it's there's just really common
patterns design patterns in material
design that a lot of people are familiar
with now because of how widely it's used
and I think there's a real benefit to
that so that a user coming to your site
or to your app
would immediately be familiar with how
the navigation works what certain icons
mean you know not everybody will but you
have there's a good chance that a decent
portion of your audience will already be
familiar with that and that to me is a
really big benefit so I agree that
sometimes it just looks generic and and
that really is it's because it's used so
widely it's just not you see it
everywhere now
so I like how clean it can look I mean
that's really nice but I mean I agree to
some extent that it's not I wouldn't use
it if I was trying to win a design
contest or something like that you know
if I was doing some project on the side
where I could be as creative as I wanted
to be I would not use it but if I'm
designing something and use your
experience in terms of just usability
ease of use was the main focus and you
know design aesthetics where we're still
important but not the main focus then
I'm definitely going to use material
design so anyway that's just that's my
opinion on it I'm certainly open to
hearing more one way the other about it
but but in a sense I mean I don't I
don't use material design necessarily
because of the the look of it itself
there's definitely other benefits that
that it brings to the table you know
more so than just the look John said
gargle with warm salt water one of the
best things for a sore throat thanks for
telling me I'll definitely have to do
that
I always forget I know that helps but
for some reason I always forget to do it
oh I'll have to remember to do that
bobble says thanks for the stream oh
you're welcome papa
thanks for watching and joining in in
the live chat Bob also says my first
time but I would like to continue these
sessions
no beer says me too yeah so that's
really awesome that it's your first time
for both of you and I'm really glad that
you want to you know continue on with
the sessions so definitely if you if you
can make it four lives for the live
streams that's really awesome because
then we get to interact you know in real
time but if you can't you know you can
always check out the recordings one of
the benefits of watching the recordings
too is that you can watch it at a faster
speed and get through it more quickly I
listen to I had heard some of you say
that you had listened to it at kind of a
faster speed and I tried it over the
weekend listening to my one of my
streams at two times speed and I
actually liked it a lot better into time
speed I think I sound like I know what
I'm talking about a lot more just
because I'm saying it all faster and it
looks like I'm typing faster too
so it definitely makes me look better at
two times speed so if you can't catch
the lies chain check that out
Antonius Asiya follow you in and Twitter
best regards awesome well you're
probably not here since you he said see
ya but anyway in case you are here you
see they're recording I appreciate
refreshing you watching and definitely I
hope you can come back for some more
livestream soon no beer says I agree
this color is so soft and looks nice
yeah isn't it isn't it I I like I don't
know what it is about this color but I'm
really liking this color anyway alright
so I'm at the the end of the live chat
and I still have my voice so that's good
but I think I need to get a cup of tea
or something now I have her my throat
but thank you so much for joining in in
the live chat I really appreciate you
all were so helpful especially when I do
things like this and try to add some
design elements that kind of go a little
bit beyond this the general material
design specifications it's so nice to
have all of you be able to take a look
at it and let me know what you think it
just it's really nice I really I
appreciate all your input I really
respect your opinions on on this and so
this is really awesome when we get to
collaborate on something like this I
think the end result is just way better
than it would ever be if it was just me
doing it
so anyways Blake and Michelle said thank
you you're welcome thank you so much for
watching and for for being in the live
chat and all right so I'm gonna wrap
things up now thanks again everyone and
I'll be back I'll be back tomorrow
probably at the same time and yeah have
a great day
you